tél
luisa but du break aux balais
[Musique]
la rue est
[Applaudissements]
bon les copains j'espère que vous allez
bien moi je vous avoue que ça fait
quelques semaines que je suis pas trop
dans mon assiette parce qu'en fait le
soleil le manque énormément et je pense
que j'ai peur j'ai plus à ces vitamines
plus en hiver ça fait un an que m'a
balancé casser du coup je peux composer
mais j'imagine ce que ça va faire
sachant que mon poids de forme
c'est moins de 58 pour moi maintenant
et là on est à 60 10 ces derniers temps
j'avais aucune motivation pour faire ça
mais comme je lé fallait dernière
si vous voulez on peut se refaire un
challenge enceinte je me suis fait cette
petite feuille je vais la mettre sur un
stade et si vous voulez ben voilà peser
vous sachant que la grèce est beaucoup
moins lourde que le muscle
vas-y folique et toi va de sa mère voilà
donc aujourd'hui dans votre alsace ont
fait de l'escrim ludique
alors c'est très marrant parce que j'ai
l'impression d'être un peu à l'école
primaire aux maternelles non ce sont des
adultes
il faut garder son âme d'enfant après
les jeux d'euros sur papier on a
transcrit ça en réel et du coup ça donne
quelque chose de très sympa voyez la
nuit est à nouveau en haut avec
aujourd'hui jamais payé que
disons que pour la musique
c'est kalthoum mon frère le gros barbare
et moi je ne sais plus comment je
m'appelle mais je j'ai un fouet et je
peux lancer le feu ici il a des pouvoirs
des pouvoirs noirs et là les filles qui
ont regardé j'ai fait les courses et
j'ai acheté plein de fruits plein de
légumes des carottes ça c'est comment
grignotage des fruits à coques voilà et
des fruits secs des pommes ça c'est
vachement bien des bananes du chou-fleur
aussi c'est très très bien ça remplit
bien des laits végétaux comme le lait
d'amande lait de soja et si vous voulez
on peut faire ça ensemble
alors du coup acheter une masse
conséquente de fruits et légumes conseil
local c'est mieux donc voilà dès que
j'aurai fin j'ai vraiment privilégié ce
garde-manger et comme ça ça me fera
qu'on s'est beaucoup beaucoup plus de
fruits et de légumes
on n'est simple dans un projet similaire
mais que jackson avait été acquitté des
10 chefs d'accusation des foyers il ya
tout un truc
allez les filles on est à fond là à deux
contre un en direct madame est en train
de nous installer la ville dit elle mais
la table quelques effets quand il m'a
proposé un croissance timide au complet
et paraît que tu te fais comme attendu
un ennemi très souvent ce dont j'avais
[Musique]
on dit pas de bêtise je filme la wii tu
vas être gagnant parce que j'ai présenté
les made in a way d'accord voilà ça te
plaît ou pas du coup je dors beaucoup
ses petits bras
[Musique]